RIA SYMONDS: We're talking
about the number 16.
16's a very special
number to me.
It's my actual favorite
number.
MATT PARKER: One of my favorite
numbers is 16.
And a lot of people
seem to like 16.
Even though it is an even
number, it wins out for being
a square number.
RIA SYMONDS: It's partially
favorite because I was born on
the 16th day of December,
to be precise.
And I always liked it because
when I was sweet 16 on the
16th, I could a lot
of things by then.
I could go off and get married
if I wanted to.
I could leave school legally.
I didn't, of course.
But 16 is also mathematically
very special.
It's the square of
a perfect square.
Did you know that?
MATT PARKER: No.
Go on then.
RIA SYMONDS: Would you
like me to explain?
BRADY HARAN: Yeah, of course.
RIA SYMONDS: OK.
BRADY HARAN: Square of
a perfect square.
What does that mean?
RIA SYMONDS: So a perfect
square, a good
example is 2 squared.
2 squared, you get 4.
It's perfect because I've
got 2 to the power of 2.
It's the same digit.
If I square this, so all of
that squared, so this is 4
squared, lo and behold, we get
16, my My favorite number.
MATT PARKER: And I was at a pub
once with some friends of
mine, and we were drinking
and having fun.
And we thought we'd
order some food.
We were on table 16.
I went up to the bar.
And I said, to get food, could
we get delivered to 16?
And I went, oh, wait, a minute,
which is 4 squared.
Can I order food to the
table 4 squared?
And it ended up the poor
girl behind the
bar looked very confused.
And I went, no, actually,
we'll make it easier.
How about I order
it 2 to the 4?
Because not only is 16 4 times
4, it's also a 2 times 2
times 2 times 2.
And then at this point, she
looked very bewildered, and
later on, we managed to
intercept our food on the way
to table 24.
RIA SYMONDS: Let's say I have
the relationship x raised to
the power of y.
So x and y are two different
integer numbers.
So x cannot equal y.
So x could be 2, y could be 3.
We'd have 2 cubed.
Now, they only relation that is
satisfied by this number 16
is that x to the y is
equal to y to the x.
So the number on this side of
your equal sign is going to be
exactly the same as the
number on this side
of the equal sign.
To do that, I'm going to take
the number x is going to be,
let's say 4.
Let's take y to be 2.
If we interpret those onto the
other side of the equation, y
was 2, and x was 4.
4 to the power 2, we've
already seen it, 16.
2, raise that to the power
4, you put it into your
calculator.
What do you get?
16.
And 2 and 4 are the only
numbers that can be
interpreted as x and y
in order to get this
relationship, this special
number, 16.
MATT PARKER: And we thought
there must be other numbers.
And we had a bit of
a chat, and we
realized none of us knew.
And we all do math things
for a living.
And we thought, well, let's
work it out, we decided.
Because you could look it up.
We could go online and see if
anyone else had tried this.
And we thought, no.
It's as much fun to work
this out as if no
one else ever has.
And some people went away and
started trying to write
computer software to see if
there were bigger ones.
And the rest of us were like--
some people were drawing graphs,
some people were doing
number theory stuff.
A lot of prime factors
suddenly appeared.
And other people--
because this went across
many evenings.
Other people were like, what
are you guys doing?
I'm like, we're trying to work
out if 16 is the only number
where you could write it x
to the y, or y to the x.
RIA SYMONDS: You cannot get
any other number using any
other integers to get a number
that equals itself.
MATT PARKER: 16 is the only
number, and we've since
realized other people do know
about this, and it's a nice
property of 16.
But we had the joy of working
it out for ourselves.
So if you get bored,
you can check why.
And it's fascinating
why 16 is the only
number that does that.
BRADY HARAN: That's
pretty cool.
RIA SYMONDS: Mm-hm.
I think so.
BRADY HARAN: Yeah.
MATT PARKER: Initially,
it was just a lot of
arguing over food.
So people walking by
just saw us eating.
And someone would go,
well, what about 64?
And then there would be
a bit of I don't know.
Then someone else wold
go, no, not 64.
Oh, OK, and we're back
to the food.
BRADY HARAN: Is that why it's
your favorite number?
Or is it just because
of your birthday?
RIA SYMONDS: Because
it's my birthday.
This is just a cool
relationship.
MATT PARKER: Often during
lessons, we'd be like, what if
it's, and then someone would
go, I've got a log.
Check out this log graph.
This is it.
And we'd go, oh, I don't know.
And actually, this was
the beginning--
if I can get distracted briefly,
is the beginning of
something called Math Jam, which
is an organization I run
where people get together
in a pub and do math.
Because we realized we started
off in this pub drinking, and
we actually did math.
And then later on, we were doing
more and more, and other
puzzles started to show up.
We realized that 36 is both a
square number and a triangle
number, but that's a whole
different video.
And we suddenly thought, why
are we having these debates
when we're meant to be
teaching school kids?
Why don't we get rid of the
school kids and just replace
them with tasty beverages?
And so ever since--
and now it's all around
the world.
Last count, 14 or 15 different
cities in the UK and other
countries have Math Jams, where
people get together on
the second to last Tuesday of
the month and talk about math,
and do problems, and
play with toys.
And yeah, all because I sat
down in a pub at table 16.